claude branche maison heureux de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
alors pour commencer que cherchent les
outils dans cette bataille pour married
est ce que c'est une pause une position
stratégique
oui c'est une position stratégique parce
que elle peut leur donner accès à des
ressources pétrolières importantes et il
est clair que les outils ne veulent pas
cesser le combat
le temps que et s'estime à siéger comme
ils disent par les forces
gouvernementales et les forces
gouvernementales aidées par les
saoudiens et les émirats arabes unis
petit qui reçoivent d'ailleurs pour pour
partie des armes de la part de certains
pays occidentaux
donc ils voudraient aussi probablement
pouvoir recevoir lui-même les outils d d
d d d d mais des armes et des munitions
par le port d'hodeida est retrouvé
l'usagé de l'aéroport de sanaa donc en
réalité ils ont déjà le contrôle d'une
grande partie du d'une partie du pays
est leur principale base se trouve au
nord
s'ils sont originaires du nord et
évidemment avec le souvenir du
nord-yémen puisque la réunification de
ce pays
avec la révolution républicaine est
assez est assez récente
donc ils vont vouloir prendre marib est
il est clair que cela provoquera comme
votre sujet le montre et bien un nouvel
afflux de personnes déplacées pour
l'essentiel les personnes déplacées à
l'intérieur du yémen d'ailleurs et donc
concourant à ce gigantesque cette
gigantesque catastrophe humanitaire à
laquelle on assiste actuellement au
yémen
puisque 16 millions de personnes
souffre dé manière ou d'une autre de la
faim ou de la malnutrition et que comme
toujours dans ces cas là ce sont les
enfants qui sont les principales
victimes
l'envoyé de l'onu est parti à riyad en
arabie saoudite pour demander un cessez
le feu
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
réalisable alors le cessez le feu
tout le monde le souhaite mais en
réalité on voit bien que les parties au
conflit ne sont pas prêtes à aller à le
réaliser à le signer et marc griffith ce
leur représentant spécial de l'onu est
en effet allé à ryadh l'émissaire
américain timothy landing également
séparément est en réalité la véritable
pression qui pourrait être efficace
c'est certainement la pression
américaine sur l'arabie saoudite
il faut en effet que l'arabie saoudite
s'apprête à être d'accord avec un
cessez-le-feu
sinon le combat continuera alors les
américains dans cette affaire ont déjà
fait un geste
joe biden a retiré de la liste
terroriste les outils il y avait été
inscrit par le précédent président
américain
et bien sûr pour les outils c'est déjà
un pas dans la bonne direction
puisque cela signifie que l'on peut
traiter avec eux et évidemment
maintenant pour eux tout dépend de
l'état d'esprit arias très long car yade
que la solution probablement se situe
mais aussi mais aussi en iran et il
semble bien d'ailleurs que les
américains aient mis ce sujet à l'ordre
du jour dans les conversations
informelles qui vont se dérouler avec
avec l'iran à la retenue cette
conférence des donateurs à genève qui a
permis de mettre en avant la situation
humanitaire très dégradé au yémen pour
autant cette conférence est ce qu'elle a
porté ses fruits on l'a vu l'onu s'est
dite déçue alors cette conférence
monsieur guti riès placé beaucoup de
d'espoir en effet et l'onu se souhaitait
recueillir 3000 3,3 milliards huit cent
cinquante millions de dollars qui était
la somme estimée nécessaire pour pour
l'aide humanitaire
on observe millions de personnes qui
sont dans la plus grande difficulté
en réalité cette conférence était aussi
patronnée par la suisse et par la suède
et les deux gouvernements sont
intervenus hier par vidéoconférence le
suédois a exclu des formules assez forte
une je cite une phrase la population du
yémen est affamé par la poursuite de la
guerre en effet il ya un lien direct
entre la poursuite de la guerre et la
crise humanitaire qui est peut-être la
plus importante qu'on ait connu depuis
très longtemps est évidemment là le
résultat est assez décevant
alors comme ce sont des appels à des
appels de fonds il n'est pas exclu que
d'autres pays continuent à faire des
promesses de concours mais pour le
moment les concours obtenus sont très
insuffisants c'est à peu près à la
moitié de ce qui avait été obtenu il ya
deux ans et c'est du même ordre de
grandeur que qui avait été obtenu
l'année dernière qui était d'ores et
déjà très insuffisant ceci marque n'ont
qu'un relatif désintérêt de la
communauté internationale par rapport à
ce qui se passe au yémen
et effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
est difficilement acceptable pour les
nations unies
encore une fois la responsabilité
principale taha cessez lé feu repose
sans doute sur les pressions que les
états unis pourront exercer sur les uns
et sur les autres
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre analyse on vous retrouve pour
l'édito de la matinale mardi brochard
merci